okay
and hot chocolate for you yes please
there's a community in Langley British
Columbia that may remind you of your own
you can go for a stroll pick up a few
items at the store or even pop by the
salon
[Music]
but this Village was purposefully built
to allow for freedom and quality of life
because every resident here has
something in common
they're all living with dementia
who's that
driving the car
it's you
it's home to Alan Maggie before moving
in Allen was a world traveler and
adventurer he climbed some of the
highest peaks on the planet and raced
cars Allen has the most adventurous life
of anybody I know he has climbed several
very difficult mountains he's cycled all
over he was even living on a boat when
he started to notice some changes it was
called the piracy and he really enjoyed
it there a lot until became too
difficult for him he couldn't remember
how to work the washing machine it was
just little things that he never had
trouble with before it became a problem
that's you Allen right there Carol Chasm
has been Alan's friend for more than 20
years she knows the village is the best
place for his adventurous personality I
think it's very important when you've
been an active person that you're in a
place where you don't feel
institutionalized where you feel a sense
of freedom and that's what you get here
in the village
I said we're gonna have this new person
that comes around every day Eleanor
jesperson is one of the co-founders of
the village in Langley the first of its
kind in Canada he worked in senior
living for about 30 years and knew there
must be a better way to care for people
with dementia having Society first of
all realize that people with dementia
are first and foremost people
they're your family in many cases
they can live a good life a different
life perhaps but still a good life
[Music]
so the five acre Village was built with
the guiding principles to make it feel
like a neighborhood
with colorful houses a farm and even a
community center
and one of the key principles at the
village is called Rome Free many of the
people living with dementia become very
agitated because they can't move about
as they wish so we said we need to build
a community where people can walk out
the door walk around come and go as they
please and still remain safe
the whole thing block around it inside
the Gated Community the people
interacting and taking care of the
villagers our staff specially trained to
work with people with cognitive decline
we want to be institutionalize The
Village as much as possible
institutions hospitals where uniforms
they wear smocks they wear scrubs we
aren't that so we just say dress as they
normally would dress
but the dementia Village Revolution
didn't start here
you need to go to the Netherlands for
that
in picturesque vespin Amsterdam there is
a village within a village
this is dejokovic the world's very first
Dementia Village it opened in 2009
for Eloy van Hall one of the founders of
the hokovic the mission was simple
you have to transform and normalize so
get rid of the institution because
people don't want to live in an
institution with the regulations and the
the way people are treated there so you
have to transform to a more normal
living environment and normal human
behavior
residents live in one of the 27 homes
spanning close to four acres The Village
has a restaurant a supermarket and a
theater because it's about being social
having the freedom to live your life
scientific research proves that
small-scale living Concepts
are much better in general for people
with dementia
so that is an important element a house
with a front door living room your own
bedroom like you have at home as well
residents pay on a sliding scale and the
village is subsidized by the Dutch
government the same cost as a
traditional nursing home and staff have
specialized training
Eloy and the team at the hokovic want to
change dementia care not just for the
188 residents who live there but beyond
the village I'm convinced and I see that
worldwide this concept can be applied in
every country where there is already
skilled nursing it's not a problem it's
how you want to spend the budget so it's
possible everywhere
and Creative Solutions which focus on
the person first will be needed as rates
of dementia are steadily Rising as of
2023 nearly 700 000 people in Canada are
living with dementia and it's been
projected that that number will soar to
close to 1.7 Million by 2050. we need to
look at more socially oriented care
social model of care Habib Chowdhury is
the chair and a professor in the
department of gerontology at Simon
Fraser University
he says Villages and other care models
that put the person first can help shape
the future with training and education
is part of the solution
he also adds that the traditional homes
that we're used to seeing in Canada were
created for more of an acute care model
to talk about the physical
infrastructure if you go to a nursing
home you feel like you've gone to
hospital setting long corridors rooms on
both sides large dining room and so on
even though Canada has a dementia
strategy the majority of care in nursing
homes is still delivered in that same
old model most of the people have some
level of Dementia in long-term care we
need to change this model in a dramatic
way we need a transformative change but
looks at the person in a more
comprehensive more holistic way
the village in Langley Allen and Carol
are visiting the hens at the farm oh
look at that
[Music]
and other villagers are in an exercise
class
good job there are 75 residents here and
it's not government subsidized so
residents pay a range from eight to ten
thousand dollars a month depending on
their care needs
[Music]
there you go
not everyone will be able to afford to
live in a village like this but the hope
is that this type of care will be an
example of what's possible in the future
just a puppy Allen he's only seven
months old
and even though Alan may be no longer
able to climb mountains or cycle across
countries his life is still full of
Adventure and dignity
I like people to realize that Alan
is a very special gentle kind soul
he would never brag about all the
wonderful amazing things most people
would brag about it but he's not like
that
he's a very kind-hearted
loving person
thank you you're welcome dear
and I mean it
[Music]